お読みください
はいバウンティーハンター追って本当にばんでるぞ
米ツアー
いや
こんばんはというべきか
始め冊だと
えっ毎回てられるのなますやです
ってすすめですね最初にですねこの企画はまあだいぶ暑くなってきたのでそろそろ言っ
てもいいのではないかということで今回も静岡県の心霊スポットを巡って行きたいと
思います浜松市っていう愛知県と静岡県の間ぐらいの場所に来ております
何かね兄ちゃんのまとめに待ったんですけども静岡県でも代表人
9本坂隧道
夢語ってるかねきゅう本坂トンネルやばいないくよー良いですか
ケバね着物を着た女性の幽霊や赤ん坊を抱いた女性の幽霊がトンネルという理屈で目撃
されている方って why のこっからですね分なんと
車のエンジンを止めてないと決してクラクションを3回なラストデイが現れるらしい
です
ためだねそんな申し上げそういう手法があるっていう押せなんとトンネルの故にはお腹
があるらしいです
なるほど
でも摂取にも女の人見てるねこれってふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ河面近くまで来てるん
で
花も入っちゃいましょう居場所その前にこうやっていくと
こうやって外スター3ですねっ病気ですねこの人英語で帰ってきました
ただいま薄暗いマイル数
あああああ目ちゃったまぁなんせ阿蘇深い意味はないんですよ勢力を行
確かにやっぱ力を高めないとスペース取ったほど心を持ってくれるとダメなんで頑張り
財布です
ro こんなダーヌー
んさつ現場で向かっていきましょうブーバーチョンドゥンクロス
ですかな日よね it 入ってすごい
ちゃん生好きすぎてコンビニ行く時とか持ってんだましたので結構
でなんか県のましたすぎてコンビニコーヒー入る時までも気になるしながら入ってない
でさせしないようかじゃないけどこう
移動するときこうやって釣っていってね回でもやってける混ぜてえっすごい
技したくなる理由県内素顔だったりまで結構長い腕を改定させ球を回転させるのはダサ
いってて
で具材あーーーーっっっ
本当の事だよさのことだけ校
3匹ずジャズ話ってまあ確かに何信じたらいいのかな
聞い深いこと言われたこっちもなんか
どうしたらいいかわかんないしうれしくはないじゃないですか
言われた本に混ぜて悲しいじゃないですか8パート2
確かによくないなっていう強い人間が一番怖いんだなっていうのは士会企画ということ
じゃないんですけど台無しだよ
それっ
[音楽]
いやながいいですよねこの買う理由がずーっと僕が深江ば
あーそ2匹かもさあ see the family スープをみすみすギーっ子
ber もういいっ
ああもう見え捉えと杉田杉田さあいるザイヤーコインだけやっぱ解体新書
ターヘルアナトミアがいよいよなことなかっただっなかったっけ
じゃないんだよねえだよ僕風捻ったみたいだ
20 a とこと全部を打つ予定
ん
なかなかだね
はいゲームしていく
んおおおおこの飯田やばい
ああってらっしゃったらでは粘りたいだ近づくにつれてこんなに見たいところ実は交換
ですけど結構いろんな走っていますよまじ
中国製くる
みんなで帰って a をくれてるみたいもかかわらず平均帰って登っ
思いますよね
だめだを送ったコピペなんか違う人だったと思います
[音楽]
別弦一そこにいくつでねー
よろしきました
帰りたくなんですよああ
すげーなー
ザーン
補助さ後ろに振ったうわーやっぱ
まじでやべぇじゃああーここはきつい梅雨でつきましたこちらが9本さがトンネルで
ございます
うわぁ民家はないの近くで真奥すぎて民家はない
ああ
やばいなぁ
ゴミ捨てんだって書いてあるゆっくりってくれてるか分かりますよ
これ怖いねこれはキツイですねちょっと今までどうぞまた別なく世界観が違う
がっ
ん
ピントがこの顔であるんだからじゃっ日
超ゆっくりでくるて気に入って持って打ってプラッタ者さ
ゲームなんかわけわかんない
[音楽]